while joining us now here on set is
tamama Kut he's an assistant professor
of public policy at the Doha Institute
for Graduate Studies good to have you
back in the studio Tama what do you make
of these reports that Israel is flooding
seawater into the tunnels or at least
testing its ability to do so uh Laura I
mean uh this this will have a
devastating like devastating
consequences on environmental
consequences on the water drinking water
Aqua fire in the Gaza Strip historically
since the creation of Israel Gaza used
to have a key River it's called the Gaza
Valley River which went which crossed
through Gaza from the middle then Israel
cut the flow this River and and then
deprived Gaza from a main source of
drinking water like you know and then uh
with the overp population Gaza it's a
very small area 2.3 million uh the water
like drinking water has been over
exploited I mean and it it it since then
it has been a serious is a problem I
mean the quality of drinking water in
Gaza it's really bad sanity is a real
issue and if Israel is planed to do this
on a major scale it's going to have
devastating consequences I mean
longlasting consequences and I really I
mean and this is something new for for
us as a human beings I mean
unprecedented experiment where you flood
uh an entire uh piece of land with with
with with seawater and and and it's very
alarming and if it is going to go ahead
with it what what's it actually going to
be able to achieve can you give us an
idea of when we say network of tunnels
under Gaza what is the actual reality
that that's an excellent question
because we hear the Israeli narrative or
propaganda when they say Network the
assumption is that you have a connected
network of tunnel that uh covers the
entire Gaza Strip no one knows because
these could be also separate isolated
tunnels uh but this is this is again
this is military Affairs no one really
knows I mean Israel did not prove that
the network is connected uh so they
don't have this piece of information so
again I think for for me it's more of I
mean if I mean yes they might do it as a
at a large scale but I think it's
they're in a trial and error phase where
they are threatening everyone especially
Palestinians in Gaza the Hamas Fighters
that they're going to use this I'm not
sure how operationally feasible is it
but if they go ahead and do it at a
large scale it's going to be disastrous
for the in Gaza what does Hamas use the
tunnels for because it's kind it's known
in Gaza is it as the
Metro yeah but but again these are all
Israeli terminologies the Metro the Gaza
Metro whatever but but I mean from the
images we have seen the Israeli images I
mean we have seen small tunnels I mean
under under few buildings or areas I
haven't seen any Metro no one has seen a
Metro where you know a car you can drive
a car or you know like a large tunnel we
haven't seen it yet I so it's it's a
taboo I mean tunnels like it's a taboo I
mean no one knows it's a military secret
we hear the Israeli Narrative of it but
we don't know exactly they have to prove
it they have to prove that there is a
network I don't know no one knows really
to be honest that's very interesting
indeed tamama kamuk thanks very much my
pleasure